on va je viens vous avez plein pot de
beauty thérapie vous mais c'est quoi oui
le oui mais c'est sa date c'est quand
j'étais jeune ya deux ans la regarder
c'est pour se sentir femme regarder ça
c'est vrai alors on fait celle et nous
voilà et ici on va tourner le bassin
façon de mollo et on tourne
yes ça vient du congo l'est pas pour ma
partie en place on raccorde à une seule
grille si je n'étais pas du boulot
les médias lui jean hieaux devenez
l'abonné isabelle morini-bosc fed est
tellement fragile que la bei
là on en fait on appelle tous les grands
danseurs là enora venez n'aura venez
jean luc lemoine vaut mieux pas je vais
ralentir comme si tu venais tous très
rapidement chacun leur tour à bout du
tchèque alors on a toujours une qui est
avec nous comme ça à chaud
j'aime bien conduire un soleil j'adore
[Musique]
ça votre s'afficher sur sa tisane la
très belle alors jorane fait qu'une
petite démonstration et après les autres
suivront je vous appellerai ici au
centre de la scène chacun votre tour
annoncé que si son attention c'est parti
à laizy d'abord jour année après je vous
appellerai chacun votre tour attention
ces pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
com
la vue
camille combal avec clément l'intrus ce
gie leverdez n hésite
[Applaudissements]
la tristesse du gars quand même jugé
lundi qu'il allait aller virginia létard
et en malaisie les deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo attention à faire un autre couple
d'enseignants calais à la fois là elle
se frotte même l'entrée saint sylvestre
à l'autre groupe
isabelle morini-bosc avec thierry bon
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je connais dans les bronzés les deux
rats gars qu'on n'a pas dans le luxe
avec la bouteille la lavalloise a eu
cela c'est mon mariage a toujours le
votre oncle et ma tante qui vont danser
un moment et tout le monde déchaîné et
ont cessé d'être dans l'ombre
soyez bien c'est exactement ça voilà à
la gelée vous allez 2 mais la tristesse
lancement fouet et l'hôtel et abats
d'eau chaude
alors on va faire un autre couple
d'années couple improbable on va faire
enora malagré avec jean luc lemoine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle aura la peau et lui mais il ferait
pas ça catala j'ai fait ma fille j'ai
fait la queue qui l'a fait s'acoquine ce
jeu vous dire quelque chose de jean-luc
hainaut belge est bonne fille allez
merci merci à tous merci merci beaucoup
gignac et julia vignali d'en inviter pas
malin quand même à sa tendance à penser
que c'est chouette de danse et où ben
oui c'est vrai mais je comptais moi j'ai
deux passions dans la vie dans ces et et
le frisbee
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je danserai qu'en présence de camille
combal applaudissements polis
[Applaudissements]
je donne en spectacle je ne suis pas
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa poule
je voudrais tu revends pour le quart
d'heure américain
je te trouvais beaucoup plus enfants
bierne
[Musique]